[Music]
hello everyone
today we are going to discuss a very
subtle point regarding the corner points
please note that in all the formulations
that we have done till now
we have considered a plate uh
which was uh which was shaped like this
so we have drawn the shape earlier
it was something like this and we had
considered
our our x axis in this fashion
our y-axis in this fashion and of course
the z
here together with this we had also
considered
the presence of the
s n coordinate system where
the n was pointed perpendicular to the
periphery
at any point and s was along the
periphery
now uh even though we did not mention it
explicitly
we had always considered this periphery
to be smooth in nature
so all the formulations that we have
done till now they
did not consider the presence of any
sharp
corner on this now why is that important
that is important because in many of the
engineering applications we do use
plates which are square shaped or
rectangular shaped or even triangular
shaped
so as soon as we have a
the presence of a vertex a corner point
then the issue that we are going to
consider that we are going to talk about
here
that arises so let me point out
exactly what the issue is and then i'll
talk about
how to overcome it all right so
uh the issue
uh will be clear if we just go back
to a previous slide where we had
obtained the final version
of our of our statement which led to the
governing equation in the boundary
condition it was in this slide number 18
or page number 18. you see these were
the various terms we had obtained and
from here we had obtained
these governing differential equations
and boundary conditions over here at the
bottom of this page
so i want you to focus your attention on
this particular line at the top of this
page
in particular very specifically you note
this particular expression you see what
we had done here
we had taken this term out from here
and we had we had used
something like uh the integration by
parts
okay over here now
uh this is where the difficulty lies
the moment you have something of a
corner point in your
periphery please note what the
problem is specifically you see
we have this this expression where you
have the presence of a derivative
with respect to s this s is tracking the
periphery please also note
that within this m and s expression you
would have
have uh derivatives of w
with respect to s and n so both within
this m and s
as well as within this term you have the
presence of derivatives
with respect to s and it is exactly that
the presence of those derivatives which
is actually creating the problem
to see even more
explicitly what the problem is let me
get back to
our page here and let me take your
attention
back to something which we have studied
uh in our
senior secondary classes that is plus
two
so let me go to the rough column here
and point out what the issue is you see
suppose we have a function
in this fashion suppose this is f1 and
let us say
over a certain domain of x this f 1 is
defined
and it is varying in this kind of a
smooth fashion
simultaneously you consider another
function
where again the independent variable is
x
and this function f2 it is
in this fashion
okay so we have the presence of a sharp
point
at a certain value of x now you see
over the domains on which this f1 and f2
are
defined they are both continuous
so there is no problem with the
continuity however
if you consider any point within this
domain
you can easily see that
those are all differentiable however if
you consider this particular point
if you consider this particular point
this point
maybe it is some uh xk
so corresponding to that a point
the value of the function f2 or or the
function in the neighborhood of that
point x k is such that it is continuous
definitely
but it is not differentiable at xk
courtesy of the presence of this
sharp point so if you
considered the the deflection variable w
to be like this function f2 then we can
immediately see
that the presence of a sharp point on
the periphery
does indeed create a problem so let us
see
uh uh i mean how exactly we
deal with that situation so for that uh
let me let me uh draw
uh let me draw in a rectangular
[Music]
instead of drawing anything arbitrary
let me draw a rectangular plate
like this where
this again is our x-axis
this is our y-axis
and down below is our z-axis
now as before
we have our
n axis like this and our s axis
present like this
however so this is along this edge
all right so let me let me uh let me
number this
vertices so this is
1 this is 2 this is 3
this is 4.
now on the edge 1 2 we have the
orientation of the n
and the s axis in this particular
fashion so n
is parallel to x and s
is parallel to y and they are both
aligned with the positive directions of
x so the positive direction of n
coincides with the positive direction of
x
the positive direction of s corresponds
with the positive direction of y no
problem
however you come now to the edge 2
3 what happens now
you see we do have to maintain the
orientation of the s
as we track the periphery so when you
come so you when you move along
the periphery from 1 to 2 the s
is directed from 1 to 2 and when you
reach this edge 2 3 you have to keep
your s axis pointed in such a fashion
that it goes from
two to three so this is the correct
direction
now you see what has happened previously
n was parallel to x now
this is our n and it has now become
parallel to y
not only that it has also now it is also
now oriented
uh along the positive direction of y
itself
however the s this is our s now
on the edge 2 3 this s axis
is parallel to x but
it is along the negative direction of x
okay so uh
it may seem to us that compared to this
arbitrary profile
we do have a certain simplicity when we
have these kinds of nice parallel edges
present in the rectangular plate or the
square plate
and that is true it does give us a lot
of
simplicity in terms of solving the
problem
uh that symmetry but at the same time
it also calls for a little bit of more
carefulness
in how we deal with this s and n
coordinate systems okay and by
by isolating or by or by focusing our
attention
on that particular term which i had
mentioned earlier
we will see how we deal with that okay
so we had this term m and s
del delta w
del s d s
this was over there in that periphery
but
[Music]
although we have written it like this we
have to understand that this
entire integration written in this
fashion or the rectangular plate
is not quite correct because when you
write like that
when you write this entire integration
over the entire periphery
okay understanding that you uh that this
s tracks then that periphery
it is not quite right to right to write
like that because
at the points 1 2 3
and 4 this sort of a derivative
the del del s term that would not even
be defined
so what actually should be written
instead of this
is a piecewise integration
so what we do is we subdivide this
integration from point p 1 to point p
2 ok so you can think of these things
as p 1 p 2
p 3 and p 4 p 4
point and we go from p1 to p2
now to keep things really really
explicit
what we'll do is uh
we will further distinguish between
the same point as it is a part of a
particular
edge and as it is a particular of
another edge
for instance what i mean to say here is
that you consider the point p2
this point p2 is very much a part of
this edge
p1 p2 it is also a part of the edge p2
p3
so when i write like this p2 which one
do i mean
i actually mean the the point or
or as we move uh or also 10 to the point
p2 moving along this one to
edge and that i denote by this
p2 minus so i am not exactly sitting at
the point p2
rather i am sitting at a point which is
arbitrarily close
to the point p2 but moving from the
from the point p1 towards p2 here of
course
it is the other way around it is p1 plus
meaning that we are starting not exactly
from the point p 1
but at a point which is slightly beyond
the point
p 1 as part of the edge p 1 p 2.
so uh and of course this integration
term whatever is present here
that is going to be present so i'm not
going to repeat it uh
over and over again so this entire
integration
is going to be like this for the edge p
two p three will be p two plus
uh the limits will be from p to plus to
p three minus
the same integrand over d s
then for the hp 3p4 we have the limits
p3 plus 2p4 minus
and you get the idea we just need to use
another integration which goes from
p4 plus
to this time p1 minus and now you see
this entire all these four integrations
they
uh cover the whole uh
the whole periphery except except really
the points that uh
that we were worried about okay so we
have
cleverly avoided talking about the
points
where the where the differentiability
was
actually an issue so what do we do from
here
well now that we have written these
things
um over domains that
that do allow these kinds of
differentiations
without any problem what we can do is we
can
actually uh carry out our integration by
parts
okay so what we are going to do is let's
go to the next page
and carry out this
carry out these operations
okay so
so what we'll have here is uh
you understand that this this thing is
equivalent to
m n s del delta w
del s okay so now
this can be written as m n s one
integration
over the second bit that will give us
delta w now the integration limits
will be utilized p1 plus
p2 minus minus
integration del m and s
del s we do the
differentiation over this first bit and
then the integration of course over the
second bit
everything within this integration
so whatever we have done for this first
term will be repeated for
all these for all the other terms okay
so let me just write
one more and then i'll just use dot dot
actually let let me write write down
everything you'll see in a while
why that is necessary at least for this
step
so this will be p 3 plus 2 p 4 minus
minus integration del m n
s del s delta w d s
p 3 plus 2 p 4 minus
and finally i will have
m n is delta w p 4
plus 2 p 1 minus minus
p 4 plus e 1 minus
del m s del s delta w
yes all right now comes the little trick
which will actually help us you see
this one m n is delta w these limits
uh when we actually write them down
explicitly it'll be like
m n is delta w evaluated at p to minus
minus minus delta w evaluated at p 1
plus
all right here it will be m n s delta w
evaluated at p3 minus minus of
minus delta w evaluated at p2 plus and
so on and so forth for the
other two square bracket terms now
[Music]
is it not possible for me to
consider those terms only and then
to rewrite them in this particular
fashion
because they are only involving the
minus and the plus
what i will do is i will take the minus
evaluated at this p 1 plus together with
the plus minus delta w p 1
divided by p 1 minus and i will consider
them together so i'll take this p 1
plus from here and the p1 minus from
this last term
similarly i will take
this p2 plus term
and then i'll take this
this p2 minus term
this is simple basic algebra
it's just that i'm writing this in the
form of the square brackets
which makes this perhaps look a little
bit um alien to us
but it is just basic plus and minus
algebra
and the rest of it are just those
integration terms okay
we don't fiddle around with those
integration terms
we keep their limits as as they are we
don't play any tricks on them
okay so uh so we just have i'm writing
this in a very rough fashion i hope you
don't mind
okay so these terms are exactly the same
as they were there in the previous step
all right now that we have this
this particular form what we can do is
we can focus our attention on any one of
these
terms if we can deal with one of these
we can deal with the rest
in exactly the same fashion and in order
to do that
let me go to the next page and do it in
a very nice explicit manner
so i'll draw the uh let me
let me
let me bring back this diagram
okay
[Music]
and what i'm going to consider is
the corner e2
so what happens there so first of all
you note this
the face
[Music]
with
edge or face
along the edge one two so when i say the
face with edge one two
what i basically mean is that
i want you to to focus your attention
on along on this particular face
so you understand that
this plate indeed has a thickness of
course
for the for the sake of clarity i have
uh have humongously
exaggerated the thickness here but it is
only for the sake of clarity i hope you
don't mind
but this is really the this this this
particular thing
that edge is what i'm going to focus on
with the edge one two
okay so here
what do we have we have
m x y is equal to
m n s and why is that
it is because x corresponds directly to
n
and y corresponds directly to s there is
absolutely no confusion
all right so let me put that in yellow
color
[Music]
next for the face
with
h23
what we have is actually m
y x you see over this
phase the if you consider the
or you refer to the x y coordinate
system then you have this kind of the y
system and the x system
this is m y x but
this is where the whole understanding
comes together
this m y x is not equal to m n s
rather it is equal to minus
m and s
all right this y certainly corresponds
to n but the
x is opposite to s that is where
it makes all the difference okay so
what is the implication of this well the
implication is
if you consider this particular term
mns delta w
from p to plus to p to minus
then this is going to give us
uh m n s
delta w evaluated at p to minus
so you understand that this p to minus
is along the edge one two
this is p2 plus and this p2 plus
is a part of the edge 2 3.
now as we have written here when it is
part of the edge
1 2 which is this
this mn is is corresponds to it
corresponds to
m x y
all right we have this minus and then
this
mns evaluated at p2 plus which means
that we are actually sitting now
on the edge 2 3
then it becomes minus of m y
x
all right
now you understand that we are talking
about
arbitrarily close limits to this point
p2
sitting over here on the edge one two
sitting over here
on the h23 so these points are arbitrary
close
to the point p2 now
we also know that mxy must be equal to
my x
so overall what this is going to give us
is
m x y twice of that
delta w evaluated at the point
p2 and it is that is what it is giving
us
okay now this basically
uh uh brings us to the conclusion
of whatever we had to do uh regarding
this
but you see the implication of this
okay i mean the algebra is quite simple
but the implication of this you note
back when we were doing or back when we
were dealing with the formulation
associated with the smooth periphery
we did not have any extra term arising
out of this integration by parts
because please go back let us go back to
that page
that i had shown earlier here you note
that as a result of the integration by
parts
the square bracket term it was
we could deal with it by starting from
one point and coming back to the same
point
and then as a result of that operation
this was simply giving us zero
so this square bracket the square
bracket was just
contributing nothing this entire term
was just contributing this integration
term
however now
if i if i come back to my page
you will see that the square bracket
term considering just the point p2
is actually contributing something
non-zero and if i go back
up to the previous page
you note that i have only considered
this particular point
if i considered the the point p
1 i will have another term
which is which will be contributing like
it twice m x y
delta w if i consider this term it will
be again contributing
a twice m x by delta w and then this
term
at p 4 will be also contributing a twice
m x y delta w so together all of these
things
they are going to contribute non-zero
things in addition to all these
terms involving the integration
so does this so what
what does this physically imply really
okay well uh
when we do problems involving these
kinds
of rectangular plates
we will see okay and
i will provide a link to the
to the github file where this is
actually explicitly discussed
uh considering a rectangular plate uh
under sinusoidal loading you will see
that
because of the presence of these
non-zero contributions
there is a very subtle
difference between the
integrated form of the load which is
applied
and the integrated form of the
of the shear that we are obtaining uh
considering just the boundaries and that
discrepancy arises because of the
presence
or the contributions from these corner
points now if i'm
when i say like this it certainly
doesn't make any sense
i understand that that is why i'm saying
uh
that when you do that problem associated
with the rectangular
plate under sinusoidal loading uh simply
support boundary conditions
so i mean it's a very straightforward
thing it's a bit long to do
so which which is why i have i have
implemented that solution using jupyter
notebook
uh but the point and that i really want
you
uh that i really wanted to highlight
through that problem uh
was the discrepancy between the value of
the total shear along the edge
and the value of the total load so it's
something like this
so let me be very brief about it that
when you consider a plate like this
and you you apply some kind of
loading over here what you expect is
that
this entire loading must be supported by
the sum of the forces
which are being generated over these
four edges that is
of course something which you would
expect even if you did not know anything
about advanced mechanics of solids
but that is where the discrepancy lies
that kind of an expectation
is not quite met because there is a
non-zero contribution
from the corner points okay
so uh so when you do that problem you
will see that um that
the difference explicitly and you will
also see very clearly and very
satisfyingly
that when you consider that contribution
from these corner points that
discrepancy gets
matched perfectly all right so on that
note i will end this video
thank you very much